[Musique]
bienvenue à la rue il répète là la ruche
c'est la petite dernière des scènes
culturelles orléanaise dédié au
spectacle vivant la ruche biz c'est un
petit théâtre où l'on peut prendre le
café un cabaret où l'on peut danser avec
une programmation très éclectique
concocté jusqu'à 1000
moi j'aime beaucoup les spectacles qui
sont avec plusieurs genres artistiques
donc par exemple les ciné concerts
ben tiens
une case au théâtre avec de la danse ou
des musiciens c'est pareil c'est quelque
chose qui me plaît
ouverte depuis novembre 2010 est la
ruche est une scène qui peut accueillir
jusqu'à 200 personnes
un lieu idéal pour les petites
formations c'est un peu la taille médium
justement entre ce qui peut y avoir
orléans justement à l'astrolabe ou le
zénith
ils sont des grosses salles l'astrolabe
une smac voilà avec une grande scène et
puis à la fois des petits bars qui
parfois voilà accueilli des concerts et
mais vraiment avec des toutes petites
scènes pour le coup et là je trouve
qu'au contraire en fait c'est vraiment
un juste milieu
la ruche bourdonne du mercredi au samedi
à partir de 18h et le dimanche
une fois par mois par mois il ya un
brunch avec un petit spectacle souvent
familiales de manière à ce que toutes
les générations puissent se retrouver et
fait passer un moment ensemble et c'est
quelque chose qui a pas du tout les
prochaines dates des festivités vendredi
19 janvier avec une soirée contes
oh
la dernière
faire manu galure fait étape ce samedi
soir aux bains douches de lignières
l'auteur compositeur toulousain
finaliste de la nouvelle star a entamé
une tournée à pied
tel un troubadour du moyen-âge il se
rendra à pinces à issoudun le 15 janvier
à bourges les 17 et le 18 à
menetou-salon rhône et ses cuivres est
se produisent à chambray-lès-tours ce
samedi soir le quatuor de cuivres a fait
ses classes au conservatoire de paris
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
aux amateurs de métal le 9 cube promet
l'apocalypse à châteauroux ce samedi
soir avec elles affichent leur chaise
radium vallée et leçons atmosphérique
d'entropia une vie tu ce dimanche 14
janvier les petits spectateurs sont
conviés à découvrir ces couacs s la
scène anglo saxon à l'astrolabe à
orléans
mammuth c'est un concert audiovisuel de
50 minutes qui rassasient tout aussi
bien la curiosité des parents avec ses
balades sonores dans l'underground new
yorkais et londonien le théâtre de
chartres programme mardi 16 janvier
parallèle la troisième création de la
compagnie express installé à jouer des
tours une partition géométriques ou
comme à son habitude le chorégraphe
abderzak houmi joue du mix entre hip hop
et danse contemporaine
bon week-end à tous